and we're live welcome everybody to
another Google hangout super excited to
be here with Peter Boog peter has a new
book out he's a multiple best-selling
author he is known for a no BS approach
to helping young entrepreneurs and he's
trained over 6,000 young entrepreneurs
and so we're here to talk about how to
go from being absolutely dead broke to
making six figures in six months with
the man Peter Peter welcome aboard
thanks man having good good good to be
here and much respect to you for the
legacy you're building man I'm excited
and I'm ready to add value cool I mean
first off I love the shirt is the first
thing I noticed and it came in until
this is part of your this party you have
a clothing line as well yeah we created
a clothing line just for Millennials and
people that really live what they what
they preach and what they believe so we
just have a couple different designs
that when they put it on they feel
motivated so that's really it's all
about motivation and making sure they're
inspired to chase their dreams so this
is one of them become legendary I like
that I like a two-man I've been someone
so yeah so I get you'll see it in the
future video me rocking the the shirt I
like it um just like really quick on
your background your story how you came
to this you know writing this book for
people who haven't heard about you
before just a quick background on it
yeah so my quick background kind of the
the simplified version is I actually
when I was 15 and 16 I was selling eBay
so I did eBay so I would buy and sale
and eventually had like a little team to
where I would I would pay people so I
got into business pretty early on my
mom's and real estate she's kind of
entrepreneur focused and I just I
enjoyed selling and I enjoyed
flexibility to be able to do things on
my terms at a young age but it's funny
after I was 17 it's so normal in society
of until I get the normal job and take
normal out so everyone's telling me hey
you got to get a normal job you're 17
you can't just do the eBay thing you
can't just do the entrepreneur thing
right at the time I was like maybe
you're right now I'm like forget you for
saying that um now I'm mad at them but
the reality is it was good for me so I
got a just a normal job valeting cars in
my town and I remember I just I couldn't
stand not not only taking older
but my paycheck being capped so I knew
at that point I felt like I was
unemployable when I lasted about two
months and I remember I added up my
paycheck and the reason I say this is
this was kind of a pivotal moment for me
in entrepreneurship
I remember adding up how many hours I
work for a week times the two months I
was going to work there actually three
months end up working only two and i
timesed out how much it was going to be
all summer and it was a certain amount
and I was like wow no matter what I do
no matter how early I show up how much I
study how much value I add to the
company how much I take care of people
how many letters I get from customers I
get the exact same pay and I'm like
that's just not fair I don't understand
that's not fair to me so I went back to
entrepreneurship and sales and got into
an international wholesale company where
I was selling products so that's my
first real taste of commission and
entrepreneurship got into that and I
enjoyed Evan helping and inspiring other
people more than I did seeing myself
succeed so I first succeeded in sales
because of persistence and hard work but
it takes more than that to actually lead
a team and actually inspire it's one
thing to be an achiever to actually
achieve success it's a whole new
ballgame when you're actually looking to
build a team and inspire and develop
other people so that was a whole new
ballgame so what happened was I did well
I I got moved up and I was going to run
an entire territory up on the Seattle
area so I was excited I'm like oh I did
really well in sales personally I could
train a team that's easy it's not that
hard to motivate people I can vote it
myself and I fell flat on my face
because like I said it's harder to
motivate others than it is yourself
sometimes so I fell on my face I wasted
all my savings I was working 70 80 90
hours a week and our society says if you
work if you're not getting results work
harder I realize that's not the case
that's the hours you put in not just the
hours you work it's what you put into
him so I was able to finally get a
mentor and was able to cut my learning
curve in half and I started really being
around high-level people and I was able
to get my income from dead broke
struggling frustrated discouraged
feeling like I let people down to six
figures within five months because of my
focus on mastery
versus overload because of mentors and
because of the blueprint that created I
didn't realize at the time Evan that it
was a blueprint I followed because I've
done it now in multiple different
industries but when I was in the
trenches a lot of stuff I studied was it
was mine said it was inspiration but
very few of the things that I actually
put in my mind and studied gave me
actual tactical advice on how to make
money as an entrepreneur so I was
reading everything I was like a personal
growth junkie I bought every program but
the reality is I was still frustrated
and broke because I was overloaded and
when you're overloaded and overwhelmed
subconsciously you seek distraction so I
was I when I invested in myself I stayed
broke and frustrated and that's why
finally when I got around the right
people the quote that changed the game
for me was if you want to be a
millionaire talk to billionaires you'll
get there quicker and I was like wow I'm
hanging around a lot of people that are
ok with mediocrity they're like hey
Peter you're young you're 21 22 it
doesn't matter if you're broke you're
supposed to be broke right and I
realized that I needed to elevate my
circle of influence and from that moment
that's when it really changed for me I
started focusing only on the relevant
information that actually was connected
to my six-month visions now I've created
a whole program based on how to it's not
just about six figures in six months
seven it's about how to have the best
six months you've ever had with zero
regrets and how to maximize your
progress whether you make 150 grand 27
grand or two million that's kind of what
it's about so now I love sharing that
with a lot of the people that I inspire
I love it man I love it I love the
passion the energy is great I get
intense I got to calm down sometimes no
I like it I love what I do for people
who recognize that for people who feel
like yeah I'm surrounded by these guys
for just telling me go get a job do the
safe thing and and you're like I'm the
only person more my circle of friends
suck like they're nice people but like
nobody around me wants to do anything
bigger for people who kind of recognize
that but they don't know how to I want
to hang around billionaires how do I do
that right so like you realize that what
are the steps that people can take
attached to go and start finding those
people
changing their circle of influence yeah
so first of all it's a conscious
decision that you have to understand you
have to give a little up to go up and I
can relate to you guys I felt like I had
no one to inspire me I felt like
everyone around me was was here's the
deal you're either hanging out with
people that hold you accountable or let
you off the hook and everyone I was
hanging out with let me off the hook so
let me give you the first step to the
six months of six figures and then we'll
dive into really the tactical side of
building and networking and elevating
your circle of influence you have to get
crystal clear and you have to shift from
complexity to simplicity first of all
get rid of all the noise in your head
and simplify everything - like I call
out my one page productivity plan and
you have to do this before you reach out
because you won't know why you're
reaching out and if you do have the high
level people you still won't have a
vision or plan so I'll give a simple
summary so on one page simplify your
entire business your values your goals
on the one page so the first thing is
kind of like an ideal statement Evan -
where if I was connecting with you in
six months
what would have had to happen for you to
be fully satisfied and excited about
your results in those six months what's
your ideal outcome it's it's scary to me
that nine out of ten people that want
more out of life that want to be
entrepreneurs that want to get to six
and seven figures I go okay what's the
ideal outcome if you take out rid of all
your limitations you get rid of all your
fears and doubts forget the past and
forget everything except what's ideal
and base it off potential what's your
ideal outcome nine out of ten what do
you think the answer is no something
smaller than what they should be doing
and or it's I don't know yeah not sure
you can't hit a target you can't see
here's the deal a genius without a road
map is going to get lost in any country
but an average person with a road map
will find their way to every single
destination so here's the reality you
have to have your ideal outcome and then
underneath that here's the big kicker
especially for for the New Age
entrepreneurship and for Millennials and
you do a lot of amazing stuff on
legendary people Steph Curry and these
kind of people
Keith Rossi who have spoken at an event
with and a lot of people that are
changing the game and you'll find this
relevant in all of them tell me if I'm
wrong
they base almost everything in their
life off their values and who they are
and what's important to them would you
agree with that true most young
entrepreneurs don't they base it off
whatever's next or whatever shiny
objects whatever it makes money you have
to sit back and gather your values and
say okay what's most important to me in
life
what's my unique ability what's my gift
right your top three or four down it
could be legacy it could be financial
freedom it could be impact could be
adventure it could be security I don't
know but the reality is once you get
your values down and you write down what
means the most to you then underneath
that on the one page you write down the
top five goals for the next six months a
lot of people say like what's your
five-year goal 10-year goal it sounds
good like it sounds good to say that but
it's not as relevant and here's what
happens if you set through your goals
trends change customers change you
change your mindset change your
standards change entrepreneurship
changes innovation happens how many
times have you ever set a goal where you
set a goal of like three to five years
in a year - you're like [ __ ] that's
actually it's a little it's different
now like this isn't even what I want I
want this now right I've done that many
times so that's why I've done a lot of
research the six-month vision along with
having a three to five year is crucial
so put down your five goals for the next
six months underneath that you want to
write down your top five reasons that
really drive you so reasons come first
results come second so when I was dead
broke before I had the courage to reach
out to people Evan I had to have such
strong reasons to pull me past the the
challenges and the limitations and the
rejection a lot of people don't have
strong reasons that wake them up in the
morning so here's what I challenge
people do write down your top 20 reasons
that Drive you why do you want to be an
entrepreneur why do you want freedom why
do you want success why do you want to
be a millionaire why do you want to
travel the world speak and share your
message here's the deal out of those
twenty or twenty five ten or fifteen or
bs they're just material things they
don't wake you up in the morning because
if you're not waking up at 5:00 or 5:30
fired up you don't have strong enough
reasons period and you're going to let
circumstance to drive you versus your
values so write down your top five
reasons that really really Drive maybe
it's your kids right I don't know but
the really it's more free time maybe you
can't stand
boss but the top five that emotionally
compel you to take action underneath
that it's the one skill you need to
develop that's most relevant to all
those five goals and that match your
values and then what you're going to do
is you're going to make sure that
everything you study everything you
listen to everything you put in your
mind is relevant to that a lot of people
just listen to a bunch of random
personal development and they're not
fully focused on mastery and a lot of
people say read 50 100 300 books a year
I'd rather master 3 than read 100 right
because it's all about getting addicted
to execution and outcomes not getting
addicted to information so once you have
that down oven that's your one page
productivity plan you let that guide you
now you have your vision guiding you not
your current circumstances or your
feelings or emotions and now when you
when you have that down you laminate it
you put it everywhere on your on your
wall in your room in your car and your
planner by your computer and then now
when you reach out to people you know
why you're reaching out so what I would
challenge people to do is a couple
things one once you figure out your
values and what industry you want a
Dominator what you want to be the best
in what you've gotten the best results
in then you you write down the top 5 or
10 in your industry who's doing the best
like who is someone a you can relate to
B has similar values to you but C is
someone that you inspire you're inspired
by you want to be like and they're a
world-class human being write down 5 to
10 and then start reaching out it's
funny out in my book by the way I uh I
put my script wet which I was kind of
hesitant at first but I put the exact
script that I use to reach out to these
people it took me a couple years of
refining but it's such a a tactical
script that works people are using it
and getting a hold of Richard Branson or
Vaynerchuk or in anyone that's this big
there's been people that reach out and
actually get a hold of them from this
script but then you have to make a list
once you have your top 5 make a list of
your maintenance friends and your growth
friends so maintenance friends are the
people that kind of you've known for a
long time maybe they're from high school
or you feel like they kind of dragged
you down but you feel bad like kind of
not hanging out with them and make a
list of those people and then make a
list of your growth friends what five
friends that you maybe don't know yet or
you know that or Channel
at a higher level and then you start
lowering your time with your maintenance
friends and raise the time you spend
with your growth friends if you can do
that you're going to start feeling your
standards raise your intelligence raise
your action rays and that's one of the
biggest keys so tactically you got to
make a list of the top five and then
it's just persistence it's reaching out
in a value-add sense and already doing
things that show you're serious when you
reach out versus hey uh I want to do all
these big things I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna be the best can I get some of your
time it's like come on they're not gonna
respond
hey Evan I've already subscribed to your
channel I've shared it with the people I
influence I really respect and value
what you do I've already left you review
on YouTube I've done this and this and
this I'd love to see how I can share
what you do with the world because I
really respect that would you respond to
that
or hey Evan I know I got big things
playing I'm gonna be the next Tony
Robbins can I have like a half hour of
your time please which one are you gonna
respond to now absolutely and you know
the people who leave the comment and are
the most engaged I already know who they
are like they've already made it onto my
radar even though they haven't asked me
for anything and if they were to ask I
would say yes because they address at
Marc and you're an authentic guy so if
you've never heard of someone like I've
been following your stuff for ten years
you're like I've never heard of you
right so it's that's the key to
especially reaching out as showing
through action that you're different
than the majority because you've taken
action it's it's surprising how many
people reach out that literally just ask
for things with zero value just as
simple as hey I've left you a review on
Amazon and on audible oh cool awesome
I've bought 10 copies of your book and I
don't say I'm not telling hey buy
everything from me and then reach out
I'm just saying
show through action how serious you are
as well if you can do that Evan and
start understanding the value of
shifting your circle of influence that's
the first step because they will tell
you what to do next a lot of people like
I don't know what to do next because you
don't have people at a higher level
telling you what action to take for me
people always ask yeah but six figures
is a lot I only was talking to people
that were making
500 grand plus how could I not make six
figures if I was making zero but I was
talking people at 500k how could how can
you not because you're taking advice
from them they're telling you what to do
what not to do
kind of what to be aware of we're not to
waste time of course I got the six
figures but it took a lot of persistence
a lot of hard work and another tip that
we can talk about is everyone has what's
inside them called a conference account
and here's the scary thing at every
moment you're either helping or you're
hurting your confidence there's no
in-between every decision you make is
either helping the account or hurting it
and every accomplishment and everything
you've done up to this point is because
of that account so I didn't realize that
a lot of things I was doing whether it
was sleeping in or validating or making
excuses they were hurting my confidence
and if you don't have confidence you're
always going to find a way to lose in
entrepreneurship so you always got to
understand how important confidence is
and protect it at the highest level and
how you how do you build confidence
well confidence is just certainty right
what's the number one reason people
won't leave corporate to go to
entrepreneurship they're scared because
they have what at their other job they
have certainty it's like well the
paychecks coming in this new economy the
only certainty you have is the
confidence in yourself and your ability
to make it happen so you have to create
certainty for your life in business by
doing your due diligence by studying by
reaching out to high-level people and by
making sure that you have an identity
that whatever you say your actions
follow because when you get results
that's the often ultimate confidence
booster you don't I mean I mean for
you--even water have you noticed when
people are making the easier decisions
consistently it kind of hurts their
confidence and then they make the
tougher ones they get the results have
you seen the confidence waver up and
down based on the decisions every day
they make absolutely and I feel like
it's a daily battle the pimp will have
to fight and so to like to attach that
so like somebody watching this right
like man I love Peter this guy is
awesome I'm going to pick up his book
and there's your on there on fire you
know it's like 3:00 p.m. here on the eco
East Coast they're all pumped up
confidence account like 100% and then
they wake up the next day and like poof
it's all gone
start over what do you tell that
entrepreneur what are like maybe in your
case like what are the habits or rituals
or routines that you do so that you
start your day with confidence you start
your day not being at zero in that
confidence account but you're starting
from a high level yep so inspirations
really what I realized Evan as
inspirations really short-term and
doesn't really last past the activity
producing it habits are what drive
people's action I go to seminars and I
mean I've spent a lot of money on
personal development because you want to
invest back in yourself and if you go to
seminars people spend like two three
five ten grand and literally five
percent of them if you catch them two
weeks later are the exact same person
because they get inspired but they don't
put it into execution and what happens
is they go back to who they were so what
I would tell people is make sure you
have a daily routine that sets you up
for success so one my prizefighter
routine a morning routine that sets you
up for success first of all there's a
lot of stuff on morning routines that's
that's fine to have like a bunch of
morning routine stuff but I'm all about
outcomes so the whole purpose of a
morning routine is two things to get you
in a better state of mind to get you
confident and courageous to take on the
day and to to have intention and to know
exactly what you're doing that day so if
you just have rituals and here's what's
cool every frustration or every kind of
failure is because there's no rituals or
systems in place right so you got to
have systems for each area of your life
so for mindset you gotta have this for
ritual every week for productivity you
gotta have a ritual every week so let me
give you an example so if you want a
mindset ritual you have to have
non-negotiables in your schedule that
you do no matter what and no matter how
you feel you start making decisions
based off standards and values not
emotions or feelings I'll tell you
making decisions off feelings you're
killing people's progress and bank
accounts and respect because if you only
do what you feel like you're not gonna
do very much how many times have you not
felt like doing a video Evan or doing
something but you're like well I have to
because I said I would has that happened
before to you we don't feel like doing
it
this happened and so what do you do if
you don't feel like it maybe you don't
do it I don't know but most people they
don't feel like it and they and they
still know they have to get it done they
just kind of get over that feeling and
they take action anyways right so have
you experienced that yeah I mean I I
find having a schedule helps me so that
every day of the week I'm doing
something different and also leave time
for like exploration of new ideas but
love it like Thursday is my
public-facing day so like hangouts
interviews shows right so Thursday were
doing this live I find that really helps
in my rituals that kind of catered to
your values and what's most important to
you and your business I like that so for
mindset so here here was mine when I was
newer to entrepreneurship and said
personal development Monday through
Thursday I only listen to personal
growth audio success audios podcasts
that were relevant to my six month
vision no news no radio just personal
growth I would then every morning I
would make sure I had my day written
down before I started my day so I used
to tell myself never start your day
without it written on paper first right
um the next thing is every morning I'd
ask myself what am I most excited about
what am i grateful for and what am I
committed to making happen no matter
what and then every week twice a week I
talked to someone that was playing the
game at a higher level than me so just
simple stuff where every week that
happened so I couldn't help but put the
good stuff in my mind and then make this
sharper decisions because one of my
rituals was making sure that I listened
the stuff that sparked my mind I
connected with people that were playing
the game at a higher level and you can't
really separate your body from your mind
when you're stronger physically you're
stronger mentally so I would also work
out five days a week so for my mindset
rituals I would work out five days a
week I would listen to personal growth
audios that were relevant to my vision
five four days a week
and then I would also look at my goals
every morning and make the decision to
have my day planned and then I would
talk to people at that point it was my
mentors that were playing the game at a
higher level than me so that's how they
do it where if they are fired up now I
challenge them don't be like most people
that are fired up but do nothing take
the excitement
it and put it into action and then make
sure that you have something tomorrow
morning that you understand is going to
help you stay consistent so have a
morning routine and the biggest thing
with confidence evan is most people make
decisions off feelings and then they
make the action and decision based off
if they feel like it or not they don't
feel like working out they don't do it
but the champions the successful people
that really live a life that they see as
world-class they make decisions first if
they don't feel like working out they
don't care they do it anyways and how do
you feel after you do that you feel
amazing right people think that they can
get motivated by just sitting around no
action motivation comes from action so
you need to act your way into feeling a
lot of times in the morning I don't feel
like working out I'm literally driving
to the gym and I'm like I don't feel
like doing this but as I walk in and
start doing it I'm like oh I feel like
doing it now so you have to act your way
in the feeling right so that's what I
would tell people if they want to stay
consistent is have someone that holds
you to higher standards and make sure
that you're doing something daily that
sparks your mind to continue keeping you
going and then once you get results and
momentum you never stop momentum
obviously the big key in business and
it's also the scariest thing is lack of
momentum right so you got to build a
positive momentum on your side like I
did finally after I was broke so it was
tough but I like how you named it to the
prizefighting routine the prizefighter
rooty I don't you're feeling ready for
the day even the brand in itself Frank
it makes you feel like you're a
prizefighter I like that like what's you
know for the people watching do you have
your own prizefighter routine or you
know what can you call it so instead of
it just being morning routine which
might be a little bland and blah but
something like right there like it
speaks to Peter's mindset right away
like if I'm creating a routine is to be
the prizefighter so I love that thank
you lots of great comments people really
appreciate all the advice and wisdom and
the you know chats blowing up people are
asking about the book asking is it is it
like a novel is it a it sounds like
there's exercises and worksheets of
people to go through can you maybe just
add a little clarity on that yes so what
makes it different and I and I'm not
it's funny I don't like saying hey this
is the best book you got to get it it's
mine but where I've seen most
of the success and why entrepreneur
magazine promoted it why a lot of the
people are buying it for their teams
we've sold over 150,000 copies was after
every it's very tactical in OBS
everything in here is very proven and
after every chapter Evan I actually gave
like action steps and I have fill in the
blank so they can actually fill it in
and they can literally take it they can
fill it in they can teach it to their
team but there's actually like work
space in there as well and when the book
was finished it was finished and then I
went through for a whole week and a half
after this was finished and I went back
in myself and I took out every single
thing that I felt was fluff or BS or
inspir too much inspiration and not
tactical I took it out so it's really a
lot of meat potatoes on how to go from
broke or frustrated and how to get the
six figures in a very genuine authentic
way not by doing things you'll want to
do not by doing things you can't stand
not by chasing shiny objects but by
understanding your unique gifts
ingenious and I just walk them through
the six muss in a very deep dive in
tactical way so yeah I mean I've got
some great feedback and I love hearing
the stories from people that not only
have made six figures from it but have
got out of being frustrated or maybe
they had a tough relationship or they
hated what they did or they didn't make
money and they were broke and they got
out of it I love those stories so yeah
anything else you want to know I can
answer but that's kind of gist of it
it's just how to go from where you are
to where you want to be regardless of
the economy cool people are asking about
Amazon links and where to buy guys I've
left a link to Peter's website in the
description so you can check that out
and click on through and I will link up
to the book and everything else that
he's up to - and it is there's an
audiobook version as well that on
audible just go to and that's what
people it's funny on the audible like I
kind of go crazy as you probably can
guess here in my my phone right now I
like it it's off the cuff so the audible
has this but also it has me sharing
different story scenarios and going off
the cuff and adding a little more value
so if you like the listening in your car
while you're working out
I'll uh I'll challenge you a little bit
so it's at audible yeah audible.com and
they just type in Peter vogue vo OGD
actually
to book seven this one is a lot more
tactical the other ones just kind of a
blueprint of my thirty biggest lessons
in entrepreneurship but this one's more
like a framework where if you literally
follow it you can't help but actually
get results from see success and do it
in like a quick way where you're not
wasting time and you're cutting your
learning curve in half because you're
not making all the mistakes that I made
sadly right I love it I'm are you but
yeah I'm also asking about finding
growth friends in the process of doing
that is that do you lay that out in the
book too yeah I give deep dive tips on
how to do it where to find people and
also it's getting around masterminds or
academies that have higher level people
one of the reasons we created the
game-changers Academy is to connect
high-level people and network people
that are ambitious they're driven and
they want to be around like-minded
people so yeah there's a lot of stuff in
the book they can check out like you
linked game-changers movement calm give
some resources as well so there's you
just have to make the definite decision
and then become aware and understand the
importance of it and then you'll find a
way if you want it bad enough I mean you
can look online there's masterminds go
to seminars join an academy or join a
membership that you fully believe in
that is proven that you know has
high-level people in there and once you
do it they can connect you with other
people as well and then it's just a
upward spiral from there that's what I
did because I I knew nobody I mean I
knew no millionaires and once I actually
got around some people that were making
a couple hundred grand then I I reached
out to people that were finally making
750 than a million so you have to work
you up you can't just go from like
making no money and no one knows who you
are to reaching out to Tony Robbins
tomorrow I wish that could happen but
it's not going to happen so you got to
kind of work your way up and get the
results and stay consistent and
persistent and follow the script I give
and it's going to happen if you
obviously get past the nose and get past
obviously the rejections because that's
part of success you know what I mean so
there's a lot of tactical stuff I love
it
Peter vogue everyone that's crazy how
quickly half an hour goes the man is
spitting fire go check them out check
out the book Peter really appreciate the
time man thinks you're spending with us
thank you guys so much for watching as
well
check out his website check out the book
I'm waiting for my hoodie it's common
shake let me say one more thing to have
and I want to share with this to people
is I know there's a lot of people that
are going to see this and if I want to
share a message it's most people spend
the first half of their life saying oh
I'm just way too young and then they
spend the second half saying I'm too old
and the reason people don't succeed that
I've seen with with 12 years of
researches they never tell themselves
now matters they're always like well
someday I'll go all-in
someday I'll join an academy someday
I'll be successful not right now because
blank and there's never the perfect time
so I challenge you guys because I
actually genuinely care about your
well-being and want to help you become a
game-changer now matters like right
after this it matters so take action
make the one-page planner and keep me
posted on your success as well and I
look forward to continuing to add value
if I can Evan and thanks again for all
you do love it man thank you thank you
guys for watching
get the book continue to believe
precision